Good evening, Tucson.
My name is Joaquin Ruiz.
I'm the Dean of the
College of Science.
And I thank you so much, all of
you, for coming here tonight.
Many of you have been with
us for many of these lecture
series.
But I have to remind you that
today is the 10th anniversary
of these lecture series.
[APPLAUSE]
And importantly, what everybody
should recognize in this room
is that although I
think we've helped
create some kind of
community through the lecture
series, which we're very
proud of, all of you
have also helped
create a community
within the University of
Arizona, just by the way
that we create these lectures.
Just to give you a sense
of how it all works out,
there's a little group
that sits down one day.
And they say OK, what's
the next lecture series?
My god, I don't know, we're
running out of themes.
And somebody will come
up with a theme that
sounds like it's reasonable.
And then we pick up our
Rolodex, and we call faculty
from the university to say
will you give a lecture.
And then they'll get
together, and they themselves
create the lecture
series as you know it.
And if I could do anything that
would be truly extraordinary
is to be able to film the deep
conversations of the speakers
as they're creating the
lecture series for you.
So they are the
ones that deserve
a great round of applause.
Because all we do is come up
with a theme and sort of duck
after that.
[APPLAUSE]
Because this is the
10th anniversary,
we felt that it had to be
something that was truly unique
and that would be memorable.
And of course, we've had many
memorable and unique lecture
series.
We've had evolution
of the brain.
We've had cosmology.
We've had genomics.
Each one of those full of
mystery and full of things
we don't know.
And the hope of all of
us in the lectures and me
is that by the time you
hear all these lectures,
you know about as
much as everybody
that's giving the lectures.
Perhaps without the
mathematics and all
these other little things.
But that you understand
all the grand challenges
and that you really sort of
get a sense of what we know.
I hope we're good at that.
I hope that we give you
lectures that stretch you,
that don't bore you.
And that in the end,
spark your imagination
about what amazing things are
being discovered by all of us.
This lecture series is
on life in the universe.
What could be more
stretching than that?
Are we alone?
Are we not?
What does that mean
in a cosmological way?
in a biological way?
And we have for you what I think
is an extraordinary lecture
series.
It has a couple of biologists.
I will tell you because,
in fact, what we
are is planet-centric.
And what is it
that we're actually
looking for in other planets?
What do we understand about
life in our own planet?
And then the rest
of the speakers
will spend their time
trying to convince you
that the science that they're
doing is worth something.
And that they know what
they're looking for.
And that maybe they
will find something.
Today's lecture is
perhaps the key lecture
in the whole lecture series.
Because Guy Consolmagno, brother
Guy, is going to try to define
what life is.
And if you're trying to find
something somewhere else,
you might as well
know what you're
trying to find if
you're going to find it.
So that's what this
lecture is about.
But before I
introduce brother Guy,
I would like to thank the
sponsors of this lecture series
that really have made it
possible for all of us
to be in this room
for 10 years in a row.
And the two main
folks that have been
giving a substantial
amount of cash to make us
make this all free
for the rest of us
is Tucson Electric Power
and Ventana Medical Systems.
And I thank them for being the
lead sponsors of the lecture
series.
[APPLAUSE]
And the other amazing
partner in all of this--
if it wasn't for
them, you probably
wouldn't even know what
we're trying to do--
and that is the
Arizona Daily Star.
They have been just absolutely
incredible in trying
to work with us to
make sure you all
know that this is happening.
[APPLAUSE]
Blue Cross Blue Shield.
The Galileo Circle,
which are friends
of the College of Science,
Godat Design-- all these designs
that you see here
are from Godat.
Holualoa Companies, Hugh and
Allyn Thompson, the Marshall
Foundation, Miraval
Resort and Spa, Raytheon,
Research Corporation
for Science Advancement,
and Vantage West Credit
Union are the other folks
that have been supporting us
handsomely for all these years.
And I thank you.
And I ask you all to
help me thank them.
[APPLAUSE]
Now let me tell a
little bit about Guy.
I urge you all to
Google Guy and Colbert.
I think that's
all I have to say.
And I don't think
I've ever seen anybody
in The Colbert Report that
actually made Colbert crack up
and be speechless.
So we're in for a
treat with brother Guy.
Brother guy got his
Ph.D. At the University
of Arizona in the Department
of Planetary Sciences.
His main interest is in
small celestial objects
and how they work
within the solar system.
So he looks at
asteroids and so on.
He is the president of the
Vatican Observatory Foundation.
The Vatican Observatory
has an observatory
in Mount Graham next to the
large binocular telescope.
I'm sure if you ask brother
Guy, he'll take you up there
and show you the
beautiful telescope.
He's written more than 200
articles, scientific articles.
He has a bunch of
books on Outreach.
This year, he was
awarded the Carl Sagan
Award in Outreach and Science.
Quite an honor for astronomy.
He's just sort of amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
After Guy got his
Ph.D. here, he went
to sort of more mediocre places
to continue his research.
He went to Harvard,
and he went to MIT.
And after that-- he felt that
since they didn't have anything
to offer-- he went to Kenya
to join the Peace Corps.
And after Kenya, he went
to the American Siberia.
And he went to
Pennsylvania to teach.
That made him a Jesuit.
And he joined the
order after that.
So I give you father
Guy Consolmagno.
Thank you.
Once again, it's a
delight to be back
in an auditorium
which I only remember
as a student for
having jazz bands.
I'm hoping that I'll be
almost as entertaining.
And it's an interesting
topic they've put up there.
What is life?
Now, life is nice.
Life is good.
But it's not really
down to earth, you know?
And I'm a geologist.
I like to be down to earth.
This is the kind of
stuff I'm interested in.
It's plagioclase.
Now, plagioclase is one
of these minerals that
appears in almost
all of the meteorites
that I study in my geology lab.
It's an essential part of
a lot of the rocks that we
have I mean, granted, we take
it for granted sometimes.
But in fact that's basalt.
But the great thing
about plagioclase
is not only can it be beautiful
with these lovely colors
and these lovely different
shapes and forms--
and now the geologists are
going to say, wait a minute,
some of those are
orthoclase, not plagioclase.
So we should really define
what is plagioclase.
That's as essential
thing to know.
Plagioclase actually has an
important role in human life.
It's the active
ingredient in the cleanser
that we use to
clean your things.
How could we live
without plagioclase?
So I suggest that
I would really like
to explore the chemistry
of plagioclase,
the incredibly complicated
chains and cages
of the plagioclase
which is formed
by these little
tetrahedral of silicone.
They've got four
oxygens on the outside.
And then they
surround the cations.
And depending on
the cations, you
can get the different kinds.
And the crystal can grow
bigger and bigger and bigger
as the larva gets
more and more--
It's fascinating.
It's so fascinating
that in fact, I
think I'm going to
change the theme of this
to plagioclase in the universe.
Today, we'll talk about
what is plagioclase.
And after we've determined
that, planet formation
and the origin of plagioclase.
Very important stuff.
It's such a beautiful mineral.
Did it just happen by chance?
Complexity.
And evolv-- what makes
plagioclase so interesting?
Hunting for plagioclase
in the sola--
there was a space probe
that went to asteroid Vesta.
I could tell you all
about asteroid Vesta.
Half of the rocks on the
surface of asteroid Vesta
are made of plagioclase.
Amazing discoveries!
We're now thinking that there's
a billion planets that may have
plagioclase on their surface.
This would be a-- I
get the impression
that if we had a seven
part series on plagioclase
in the universe, we might
not draw the same crowd that
came tonight.
I gotta admit, I gotta admit.
This is an important
thing to remember.
If you're going to define life
in terms of its chemistry,
if it's long chain molecules,
of its beautiful structures
and forms, you're going to
have to keep asking yourself,
is this really what makes
life interesting enough
to have a seven part series.
And if we come up
with a definition that
is no better than
plagioclase, then we've
missed something
essential about what
makes life fascinating
and important to us.
So let's drink to life.
I was once a rabbi-- in the
MIT production of Fiddler
on the Roof.
When you ask what
is life, you can
ask the philosophical
question, what
gives me the fullness of life.
In other words, what
is at the center
of what life is that makes
life interesting to me.
The philosophy
question is concerned
not so much with distinguishing
life from non-life,
but from actually figuring
out what life itself is.
The scientific question,
on the other hand,
might be more what are the
criteria I can use to determine
life from non-life.
I went to a book,
Biogenesis by Norm Lahav.
Theories of life's origin.
And in the center, he has
48 different definitions
of life dating to the
middle of the 19th century.
We're going to take a
look at some of those.
But before I do, I
want to remind you
that there are three different
kinds of definitions.
All of them important,
all of them different,
all of them hopeless.
The boundary definition that's
a life, that's not life,
there is the boundary.
Well, I think
that's pretty easy.
Life is anything that
occurs on a planet
rather than a dwarf
planet, right?
Those of you who fought the
Pluto wars will get the joke.
It's easier to define
what's a planet
and what's not a
planet sometimes
than to divine what's
life and what's not life.
The central question
is what is it
at its core that makes
life something that we're
going to have a packed
house for seven weeks trying
to figure out what it is.
But for the scientists looking
for life in the universe,
the much more
practical question is
what's the gizmo we can
build that will give us
a yes or no answer that
everyone will believe?
Now, we've got Carl
Sagan here next
to a model of the Viking Lander.
Viking landed on Mars in 1976.
And it had three
experiments that
were going to look for life.
Four, actually.
Because Carl
insisted it also had
to have a camera, in case any,
you know, silicon giraffes
walked by.
I won't go into the
details of the experiments
except to say that when
they got the results back,
they knew that if
they got this result,
it would mean there was
some life on the surface.
If they got that
result, it would
mean there was no
life on the surface.
And instead, they
got a third result.
Because they had made too many
assumptions about what life
would do, and they had
built their experiments
to look for what they
were looking for.
The philosophers of science
say that every experiment
is theory laden.
You do the experiment
knowing ahead
of time what the answer
ought to look like.
And you have to.
Because otherwise, how would you
know the answer if you saw it?
But this has been an issue
in trying to figure out
how to search for life ever
sense we've been thinking
of searching for life.
Now, I mentioned
the 48 descriptions.
Here's a couple of them
I want to share with you.
The vital forces are
molecular forces.
It's TH Huxley.
Huxley and Darwin--
well, let's just
say if you ever saw the Marx
brothers where they're out
of college, the
two colleges were
Darwin College
and Huxley College
and they were the big rivals.
1868, that's important.
Because this is the time when
most of science is convinced
that Newtonian physics has
the answers to everything.
There was a great
physicist who should
have known better, who
once said all of science
is either physics
or stamp collecting.
But the vital forces--
there was a theory
going around that
said that there was
some kind of-- called vitalism.
And that there was some magic
force that created life.
And Huxley saying
no, the only force
that's happening
inside a living entity
are the forces in the
molecules themselves.
This is the height of
the mechanistic view
of the universe.
It's a very Victorian view.
It's a very naive view.
It's the view most
biologists have.
[LAUGHTER]
And thus Browning,
a year later, could
say there is no boundary
between life and non-life.
Now for the Marxists
in this room,
Frederick Engels
points out that death
is an essential factor in life.
If you can't kill it,
it was never alive.
Well, maybe.
By 1929, life can be eliminated
from the scientific vocabulary,
since it is an
indefinable abstraction.
But of course by
1929, we're already
beginning to see
that the world is not
quite as simple as the Newtonian
mechanists wanted it to be.
So we have Horowitz
in 1959 saying well,
we can make a list of
things that life does.
Mutability, it changes.
Self-duplication, it reproduces.
Heterocatalysis.
Ooh, I like that word.
I had to look it up in Google.
I probably have it
wrong in my memory.
Basically a catalyst,
as you might recall,
is a little lump that doesn't
change at all during a chemical
reaction.
But it promotes the reactions.
And there are autocatalysts
which make more of themselves,
and there are
heterocatalysts that
make things that are a little
bit different from themselves
but continue to be catalysts.
Now, we've got the 60s.
How many people here
remember the 60s?
You weren't there.
Self-realization of
the potentialities
of atomic electron state.
Ah!
That explains it.
Now I know what life is.
I can build a machine that
will look exactly for that.
Multiplication,
heredity, variation.
Kind of a similar
system as before.
By 1997, we're into the
electronic age, the computer
age, the information age.
So now we know that life is
a flow of energy, matter,
and information.
What is information?
Oh, we should have a seven part
series on what is information.
Information in the universe.
This book itself ends up with a
definition that having evolved
from inanimate matter,
life constitutes
autocatalytic, evolvable,
telenomic organic systems
that can transfer, store,
and process information
based on template and
sequence-directed reactions,
all of which characterize
autopoietic entities.
So I've got a list
of words up there.
If you can find synonyms
for them in one syllable.
Autocatalytic, it
makes more of itself.
Evolvable, it can
make more of itself
but change into something else.
Telenomic and organic.
Organic just means it's
full account of carbon
as far as the chemists
are concerned.
Telenomic is a wonderful word
because it's really tempting
when you're doing
evolution studies to fall
into the characterization
of saying well,
this animal evolved
the human eye
in order to be able to see
to hunt better as if there
was a direction, an end,
a teleology directing
the evolution.
Now, the word
telenomic was invented
to say the same
thing without making
that kind of implication.
But other than that, I
can't tell the difference.
Maybe some of the
other biologists
will get into the subtleties
of the difference.
Again, we have
transferring, storing,
and processing information.
As if we knew what
information was.
Because, in fact, what's
information to one
operating system
is random jibberish
to another operating system.
It's based on template and
sequence-directed reactions.
Basically, they're
talking about DNA
and how the atoms line up
and reproduce themselves.
Autopoietic-- they
reproduce themselves.
So they're reproductive
objects that reproduce
into reproducing objects.
Lucas Mix is going to be
giving a series of talks.
He used to be the
Episcopal chaplain here.
And he's also a
biologist now at Harvard.
And he's come up with
other definitions
he's seen through
history, Wouse & Fox.
Anything that can be
related to the tree of life
must itself be alive.
Which is really limiting
if you're trying
to look for life elsewhere.
Darwin, anything that
evolves by natural selection
will be alive.
So if I'm going
to go to a planet,
I have to stand and watch these
entities for about 10,000 years
to see if they change.
Haldane, anything
with homeostasis,
maintains chemical equilibrium.
This is a little bit closer to
the kind of working definition
that most people
are interested in.
Because one of the
characteristics of life
is that it is, among other
things, a chemical process.
And it's a chemical process
that maintains an equilibrium.
But it's not a particularly
stable equilibrium.
Now, when we're teaching
freshman physics,
we try to give the
idea of an equilibrium.
You have a valley.
And you roll the ball.
It goes bum-da-dum-da-dum.
It sits in the
bottom of the valley.
And it's at equilibrium
because it's not moving.
And it's stable because there's
no place it's going to roll to.
If I have a hill
and I put the ball
at exactly the top of the
hill, it's at an equilibrium.
Because it's not going
to move because it
can't decide which
way to-- it doesn't
roll one way or the other.
But it's not a
stable equilibrium.
Because the slightest breeze, it
goes woosh and then it's gone.
If you have a hill and then
a little dimple in the hill,
you might have
something akin to life.
While it sits in the dimple,
it's in a local equilibrium.
But it doesn't take much for it
to completely leave that place.
And once it leaves there,
it can never come back.
Maybe the hill without
the dimple is even best.
Because you've got a little
ball that's in equilibrium.
But then you have to
keep blowing on it
with little gas jets or
something to maintain it.
You need energy at the outside
to keep it at equilibrium.
This idea actually goes back to
Kant, Critique of Pure Reason.
But then everything
in science goes back
to Kant and the
Critique of Pure Reason
so that doesn't
tell us anything.
One of the more
interesting takes
in the history of
what is life questions
comes from Erwin Schrodinger.
Now Schrodinger is
not somebody you'd
think of as being a biologist.
Schrodinger certainly did
know that the mechanistic view
of 19th century
doesn't work because it
was his theories and his
explanations of quantum
mechanics that showed
that it doesn't work.
Schrodinger is
probably most famous
in the world of biology
for Schroedinger's cat.
Schroedinger's cat is
a way of explaining
how quantum physics works.
I won't try to explain it here.
Because whenever I
try to explain it
to my students, first of
all they get very confused.
And then secondly, they
feel sorry for the cat.
[LAUGHTER]
But to give you an idea of
what he's talking about,
take a look at this interesting
film pulled off YouTube.
It's alive.
Little bugs moving around.
Actually, it's not alive.
Each of these are particles
less then a tenth or a hundred
of the size of a human hair.
We're able to see them by
shining a laser through them,
and the particles will forward
scatter the laser light.
And they're in water.
And water has a
certain temperature.
Because they are so small, the
water molecules hitting them
from every direction
do not completely
hit them at the same
rate in every direction.
Once you get small
enough, there's
going to be, from
moment to moment,
a mismatch in the number of
molecules hitting this way
and the number of
molecules hitting that way.
And as a result,
the little particles
move back and forth in
a totally random motion.
Robert Brown figured this out.
He saw this in
pollen in the 1830s.
It's called Brownian motion.
And it's simple enough that
people immediately understood
it after they read Einstein's
paper about it 100 years later.
One of the things
about this image
is that it's only
about a minute clip.
And I'm running it
backwards and forwards.
And you can't tell
the difference.
At the scale we're looking at,
there is no time arrow of time.
But what this
shows, first of all,
is that things moving
isn't enough to declare
that something's alive.
And it reminds you that at small
scales, the laws of physics
are no longer absolute.
Rather, they are probabilistic.
All you can say is that on
average, those particles
are going to be in one place.
On average, the
particles don't move.
But at any given
moment, they might
be moving one way or the other.
Thinking about this,
Schrodinger pointed out
that to do biology in terms of
a mechanism and a chemistry,
you've got to have laws
that absolutely work.
And work exactly the
same way all the time.
You can't have lots of
randomness throwing things
into the world.
Because though we
do have mutations,
mutations are slow and gradual
and take years to develop.
They can't be happening
every couple of seconds.
But the laws of physics only
give you that kind of certainty
when you're looking at
really large things.
Where the probability
of a very large ensemble
averages out so that
you can predict what's
going to happen from
moment to moment.
If nothing else, this
tells him that life
must be based on genomes that
are really, really, really big.
And of course he
wrote this in 1994,
almost 10 years before DNA
was finally worked out.
And the idea of the
macromolecules that formed
genomes were truly understood.
When it comes time to
dry and determine life,
the temptation is to come
up with these laundry lists
of what life is and
what life doesn't.
But the longer the
list, the more likely
you are that you're going
to be ruling out something
you actually think is alive.
Multiplication,
heredity, variation.
Mules don't reproduce.
But they're alive.
Jesuits don't
reproduce and they're--
[LAUGHTER]
Dual income, no kids dinks.
You yuppies.
You don't-- and yet
you're still alive.
It can't be merely reproduction.
It can even be the
possibility of reproduction
that makes something
alive or not alive.
What's more, there are
plenty of things that
do reproduce that aren't alive.
Fire reproduces.
Plagioclase crystals reproduce.
If you make a short
list to try to stop it
from being overly
dependent, you can
find lots of these examples.
Mutability, self-duplication,
hetero-- OK.
Are computer viruses alive?
They reproduce.
They can mutate if you merely
make them clever enough.
Heck, computer viruses--
what about real viruses?
Great debate.
What about-- one of the
biologists kept saying
don't forget prions.
Prion, that's a Japanese
sport car, right?
The prion a prion
is a protein that's
been folded in a funny way.
And then when it gets
introduced into a cell,
it induces all
the other proteins
to fold itself the same way.
And what you're left
with after a while
is something like
mad cow disease.
It reproduces.
But no one would say that
the prion itself is alive.
None of these
definitions are useful.
If we only have
a snapshot, we've
landed our Lander on Mars,
we've only got a year
or so to look at something
to determine whether or not
it's living.
So these fail both in
that they don't really
draw the boundaries where
we know the boundaries ought
to be drawn.
They fail in that
they don't give us
a way of making
a machine that we
can run the crucial experiment
and say yes, this is alive, no,
this isn't alive.
And of course none
of them answer
the philosophical
question, why am
I interested in
this entity instead
of a lump of plagioclase.
The answer that you usually
get after hours over a beer
when you talk to
a biologist, it's
like the definition
of pornography.
I don't know what it is,
but I know it when I see it.
The trouble with
that definition--
which fundamentally is
the definition we're all
going to be using--
is that it does
have certain cultural
assumptions built in.
Here is an example
of a great case where
that definition, that I know
it when I see it definition,
won out over all the
other definitions.
About in 1984, a meteorite
was found in Antarctica.
And it was found
in the Allan Hills.
And when they looked
at it, they said
this is really interesting.
Tell the guys back at NASA
when they open the bags,
open this one first.
And so it became Allan
Hills 84001, because they
knew it was the most important.
Sure enough, it had all
of the evidences which
said chemically,
isotopically, age
dating that it was from Mars.
That's another hour long
lecture if you really
want to get into that.
In 1996, a group of scientists
at the Houston Johnson Space
Center in Houston looking into
this found a number of things.
In this meteorite, was the
oldest Martian meteorite,
was four billion years old.
It dated back to a
period in Martian history
when there was probably
a lot of water,
when there was a lot
of carbon dioxide
because there are
carbonate minerals.
So if there is ever
going to be life,
there might have been
life at that time.
And they found this little thing
that looks just like a bug.
Fossilized bug.
But wait.
Along with that, they
found polycyclic aromatic
hydrocarbons.
Which is the kind of
gunk that comes off
of your steak when you've
burned it too long in the grill.
It's what happens
when life dies.
They also found
crystals of sulfides
that are always associated on
earth with living creatures.
And they also
found tiny crystals
of magnetite, which within
their limits of the resolution
were not inconsistent
with the possibility
that they were the kinds of
pure magnetite crystals made
by bacteria in order to let
them use a magnetic field
to know whether to
swim up to the light,
or down away from the light.
Four independent lines of
evidence all saying this
is a body that was formed
when there was life around.
This
Made it into the popular press.
This made it into--
the president
had a news conference about it.
Excuse me.
It was presented at
scientific meetings.
No one in the field
doubts that the evidence
was as they presented it.
They have been arguing
about whether or not
the crystals really were
this kind of crystal or that.
Because it's also not
inconsistent with other kinds
of crystals.
But it's not like no one
could reproduce the evidence.
You take the rock, you can find
stuff more or less like this.
Nonetheless, 20
years later nobody
believes that it's
a hard evidence.
And one of the
people who will talk
to you more about
this, Tim Swindle,
has a great story about this.
I'll merely say
that when he talked
to people soon afterwards,
well, half the room would
say it's worth looking into.
And the other half
of the room said eh.
They're all looking
at the same data.
But it didn't pass the I'll
know it when I see it test.
And that's really the
only test it didn't pass.
Occam's razor.
Occam's razor says that if
you have multiple hypotheses,
you choose the simpler one.
So maybe that's actually
just an optical illusion
that comes from weathering.
Maybe the polycyclic
aromatic hydrocarbons
came from the exhaust
pipe of the SkiDoo
in Antarctica that had
pulled up next to the rock
when they recovered it.
I was in Antarctica, I know
how they recover these things.
Maybe the sulfides were
made by other processes
that have nothing to do with
life, which we know happens.
Maybe the magnetite
crystals are actually
a different kind of crystal and
they're kind of fooling you.
Which is the simpler answer?
Four lines of evidence
that can all be explained
by one hypothesis, life.
Or four lines of
evidence that all
can have non-life explanations.
There is no calculus
that will tell you
which is the simpler one.
At the end of the day, you
just have to look at it
and say could be, I don't know.
Let's move on.
The big trouble with
the I'll know it
when I see it, the
common sense approach,
is that common sense
has changed over time.
Back in the
pre-scientific world,
where the world
was flat, there was
water above and below the earth,
a dome holding the water above.
And if you dig deeper now,
you get that water again.
This is not something
out of Genesis.
When the guy wrote Genesis,
the author of Genesis
took the best
science of their day,
which is Babylonian science.
Which is based on the
fact there is a flat earth
with mountains at the edge.
Go outside tomorrow
morning in Tucson.
Flat ground, mountains
around the edge.
There's a dome.
If you don't see it, you
are not paying attention.
These were good observers.
They were seeing what
anyone could see.
What they also saw was
that things that were dead
stood still.
And things that
were alive moved.
What's more, the wind
can make things move.
And when animals breathe, they
have wind going in and out.
So they used the same word,
anima, to mean the wind,
to mean the soul, to mean
the definition of an animal.
Rivers flowed because there were
living creatures in the rivers.
The gods of the rivers, the
goddesses of the rivers.
The trees had gods
and goddesses.
Everything that moved was alive.
Now the Greeks had a little
more sophisticated way
of looking at it.
Everything that moves is
alive except of course things
that go up and down.
Because rocks falling
due to gravity-- well,
they didn't call it gravity.
Rocks falling due to the
fact that Earth is trying
to reach its natural place.
Water that bubbles up from the
ground when the rocks fall down
because it's trying to
reach its natural place.
Bubbles in the water
that bubble to the air
because it's trying to
reach its natural place.
Fire in the air
that's going upwards
because it's trying to
reach its natural place.
Gives us the four elements
and the four natural layers.
That kind of motion is obviously
nothing to do with life.
But backwards and forthward
motion cannot be explained
by this up down force.
And you look in the sky and
you see stars that move.
And planets that move among
the stars in sometimes very
complicated ways.
So clearly, the
planets themselves
were imbued with
planetary intelligences.
And they somehow
communicated with each other,
sending little demons,
little geniuses.
And if you happened to be
born when the genius of music
was overhead descending on
you, you'd be a musician.
If you happen to be born
when the genius of sleep
was descending on you, then,
well, I've been like that.
Now we laugh at the idea
of demons and geniuses
communicating.
I'll talk to a
particle physicist
about virtual photons.
Sounds very similar.
What was also in
Aristotle's philosophy
was the observation that
if you have muddy places,
you'll find animals in the
mud coming out of the mud.
If you leave food
out, after a while,
even though the food
is dead and rotting,
animals will appear
within the food.
Different kinds of mud produced
different kinds of mollusks.
So clearly, we have the
spontaneous generation
of life out of
inanimate material.
You find this even
in Shakespeare.
Where in Anthony and
Cleopatra, they're
talking about the snakes
and crocodiles that
come from the mud of the Nile.
To illustrate
this, I went online
and was looking at
pictures of maggots
and pictures of rotting meat.
And decided you'd probably
rather see a picture of Pasteur
How was this disproved?
Well, Radian, 1668,
did experiments
where he covered the meat so
that flies couldn't land on it.
And left other meat uncovered.
And by golly, the maggots
only appeared where
the flies landed on the meat.
Pasteur had a much
more complicated series
of experiments.
It's usually described as
oh, he put them in bottles
and sterilized them.
It's a lot more
complicated than that.
He was a very good scientist.
And he pretty much
showed that you could not
explain-- you could not
observe life occurring anyplace
that had been sterilized.
You can only see
life occurring where
there was contact and possible
contamination from microbes.
This still left the question as
to what made life so different
from non-living things.
Because there is such a
quantitative difference
between a rock and a maggot.
Was there some essential
ingredient, some vital force?
If we had that vital
force, could we
stick it into our monster
and create the Frankenstein
monster?
Or alternately, if
there is no vital force,
then why shouldn't we be able
to take pieces that are almost
alive and get them going again?
One thing that was
known by the chemists
in the early 19th century was
that organic chemicals which
were rich in carbon were a
heck of a lot more complicated
than inorganic chemicals.
And every organic chemical had
been made by an organism until
Friedrich Whler by
accident synthesized urea.
And said oh, I made this
without any life around.
You know, I did this in 1828.
It's only a matter
of time before we'll
be able to create life
in the laboratory.
200 years later.
Even Pasteur
himself was not sure
whether or not there was
this vital action going on.
Furthermore, we have
to remember in worrying
about life in other universes,
life on other planets,
or even life here on
earth, that we have never
lived in a time where
we didn't ponder it.
Whether we're talking about the
creatures of ancient Greece,
the mythologies of all
the ancient cultures,
the first travel
to other planets
science fiction story
which dates from AD 160.
Even the Bible has got the
Nephilim, the sons of gods.
And angels for that matter.
How would you know
it if you saw it?
Well, I come to science
through the very, very
holy and important gateway
of science fiction.
[LAUGHTER]
And one of the great
masters of science fiction,
Gene Roddenberry, the fellow
who invented Star Trek was once
quoted as saying if I'm going
to put a creature on television
and I want people to
believe that it's alive,
it doesn't matter what shape it
is, it doesn't matter what form
it is, it doesn't matter
how many tentacles it has,
it doesn't matter
what color it is.
As long as it's got two eyes.
Then everyone will
know that it's alive.
Our sense of what is living
and what isn't is deeply
embedded in the
culture we live in.
And we cannot remove
ourselves from that culture.
What do we know about
life on other planets?
Well, what do we know
though about other planets?
As soon as Galileo
and Kepler working
on the theories
of Copernicus had
convinced the scientific
world that planets
were places like the
earth, or that earth was
a place like other planets--
And a little hobby horse
by the way, don't ever
think the medieval
world view was
that the Earth was
special for being
at the center of the universe.
Because if you read Dante,
you dig through the Earth,
what's actually at the
center of the Earth?
The lowest realm of the inferno.
That would mean the inferno
was the most important place
in the universe.
No, no, no.
They thought the Earth was
the bottom of the universe.
When Copernicus said the earth
is a planet like other planets,
it was promoting the earth or
demoting the other planets.
But as soon as that
idea was out there,
Kepler and Wilkins and
Godwin and de Bergerac
are all writing stories about
traveling to other planets.
And what good is a story if
you don't have people around?
So it's traveling
to other planets
and interacting with
other creatures.
Kepler, you know,
is the astronomer.
Godwin was a bishop.
De Bergerac was the great
swordsman with a big nose.
It was, actually.
Conversations on the
Plurality of Worlds.
This was a book
trying to describe
a conversation between a
countess and a philosopher
on what lives might
be present and could
be possible on other planets.
Not just around our sun,
but around other suns.
These are speculations
that go well
into the 18th and
19th centuries.
We look today for
evidence of life
on planets recognizing
that we have
both our cultural
assumptions and the fact
that we're fighting against
those cultural assumptions.
There have been bursts
of methane seen on Mars.
Well, that was seen
first by a telescope,
but the evidence
wasn't very good.
So now they put a lander
with a little detector
to actually look for methane
from a detector on the lander.
And they have found
little bursts of methane,
which go away really quickly.
Which means they're being
produced by something.
Rotting, decaying
organic material?
You know, the
flatulence of cows?
Who knows.
It could also be outgassing
from the spacecraft that's
holding the little instrument.
We have looked at icy moons,
like Europa and Enceladus.
And we have excellent
evidence that there is
liquid water under the crust.
What's the excellent evidence?
Every now and then,
you can see some
of the liquid
water squirting out
through a crack in the crust.
It's probably there.
The first time anyone
talked about life
in an ocean of Europa was here
at the University of Arizona
at the Jupiter meeting in 1975.
And it was a smart aleck-y
a young graduate student
who made the suggestion.
And when I made that suggestion,
Carl Sagan turned to
me and said if you've
got 100 kilometer crust of
ice, or even a 10 kilometer
crust of ice, how is it going
to get sunlight into the water
to drive the life?
That led to a whole
series of other arguments.
Can you have a life where
there is no sunlight?
It's not as clear as you
might think either way.
One great place that has been
suggested for life is Titan.
Titan is a moon of Saturn.
It's covered with an atmosphere
that's rich in nitrogen. Sound
familiar?
But 1.5 times the
pressure of the
atmosphere here on
earth, not that bad.
It's got mountains, it's
got lakes, it's got rivers,
it's got evidence
of rain occurring.
Of course it also is about 200
degrees below zero Celsius.
How do you have lakes there?
Because they're
not made of water,
they're made of liquid methane.
Could you devise life
that could function
at a really low
temperature like that?
Well, maybe nature is
very clever and it can.
I remember this was discovered
by the Huygens probe, which
was a probe built by
a bunch of Europeans.
I lived in Europe 20 years,
I've gotten to know them.
Some of my best
friends are Europeans.
One of them from the
Netherlands came here
to give a talk at the
lunar lab a few years ago.
And he said we've
done calculations--
this is before the
lander actually
got to Titan-- we've
done calculations
on the atmosphere of Titan.
And it looks like the clouds
should be liquid droplets just
like water clouds on Earth.
And there should be rain
that falls out of the clouds,
just like rain
falls here on earth.
But if our calculations
are correct,
that rain might
actually evaporate
before it hits the ground.
Who ever heard of such a thing?
Until we explained to him go
outside in the desert here
and you see it all the time.
Our assumptions
of what is normal
are so deeply built
into our own experiences
that it's very hard to break out
of those cultural assumptions.
It gets even worse
when you start looking
for life on other planets.
There are thousands of planets
we have confirmed that we have
seen around thousands of stars.
Of those, we already
know of a dozen or so
that are close to being
earth like in size.
And another dozen that are
close to being in regions that
appear to be where water would
be neither too frozen or too
boiling to allow [INAUDIBLE],
so that we could actually
have life present, the
so-called Goldilocks zone.
And of those dozen,
there's actually
one or two that are both.
They're earth like
and they're in regions
that might have liquid water.
If life is this weird out
of equilibrium chemistry,
if life is this thing which is
balancing on a teeter point,
what's doing the balancing?
Schrodinger had a wonderful
description of it.
He said life consumes
negative entropy.
That explains it, right?
It means that there is
a source of energy which
is allowing these incredibly
complicated chemicals that
make us alive continue to exist
even when the sun goes away.
So that we can still
survive even at night.
The way we do it on
earth is that we've
got plants that take the
equilibrium product, carbon
dioxide, and break it into
free oxygen. Oxygen is
the second most reactive
element in the periodic table.
Oxygen wants to react
with everything.
It wants to react with the wood.
It wants to react
with your clothing.
That's why we have
fire departments.
And because we can use this
chemical reaction day in
and day out, even
though it's only
produced during the daytime,
we can maintain ourselves.
But as a byproduct, we have this
really reactive chemical agent,
free oxygen.
Another reactive agent
like that, methane.
If the temperature is
such that really methane
shouldn't be in equilibrium
but you see it anyway,
it's a biomarker.
And free oxygen and
methane are the kinds
of elements that can
be pretty easily seen
in the atmosphere of a planet.
So if we're going to use this
chemical reaction to describe
what life was and look
for the products of it,
we might be able to see it.
We might be able to
say that this is not
inconsistent with the
possibility of life there.
But it's never a proof.
And in the meanwhile, the
science fictional people
can come up with
marvelous examples
that we haven't
thought of yet, that we
wouldn't see if we have
our expectations of life
too narrow.
What is life, and
how does it function?
Life arises out of the
spontaneous reactions
of inanimate-- that's
spontaneous generation.
No, actually that's what every
theory for the origin of life
ultimately says.
It doesn't go so quickly
from mud to a mollusk.
But whether it
happened overnight
or it happens over a
period of a billion years,
ultimately our chemical
theories of life
still assume some kind of
spontaneous generation.
From all we have learned about
the structure of living matter,
we must be prepared to find it
working in a manner that cannot
be reduced to the
ordinary laws of physics.
Vitalism.
No?
Schrodinger pointing out that
you have to-- at the scale
that things are
happening in biology,
you have to take account
of quantum effects.
I know it when I see it.
What if you were raised
on a desert island?
In the desert island,
surrounded by trees.
And you had a pretty good
idea of what a tree was.
And then somebody
showed you that.
How would you know that
that was also a tree?
You need more than
one example to be
able to determine what
are the essentials
and what are the accidents to
use the words of Aristotle.
I know it when I see it.
What are the characteristics
that tell me something
about the center of what
it means to be alive?
Some of the things
that I hope I would
be able to see in any
entity that is alive.
Life does change.
It changes both for the
better and for the worse.
And sometimes these changes
occur simultaneously.
And sometimes you can't be sure
what is better, what is worse.
This is a photograph
of Pope John Paul II.
When I first arrived at the
Vatican more than 20 years ago,
I got to meet Pope John
Paul II as a young man.
Very well-educated,
very sharp, great guy.
Wonderful skier
I have to confess--
don't tell anybody,
as long as it's just among
us-- after meeting him
the first time, I was
a little disappointed.
Because he was just a guy.
He puts his cassock on one arm
at a time like the rest of us.
But he got older, and he got
weaker, and he got more frail.
And by the early 2002,
2003, 2004, an amazing thing
happened when you saw
him in a public audience.
We have these summer
schools, we bring students
from around the world
to study astronomy.
And at the end of
the school, they
get to meet the pope usually.
And some of the students will be
Catholics and they say oh cool,
I get to meet the pope.
And some of them would
be harsh atheists.
I don't want to
meet this pope guy.
And after they met John
Paul II, the Catholics
would go yeah,
that's pretty cool.
I got to meet the pope.
And the atheists
would go oh my god.
Oh my god.
Because, and I don't
know how to describe it,
but there was something
about this guy.
Agree with him or disagree
with him, love him or hate him,
you know, follow
his theology or not,
he had a power at
the end of his life
that he did not have when
he was young and vigorous.
People change.
And the changes are complicated.
Living entities
are unpredictable.
Like the little things going
around in Brownian motion,
but they are not random.
If you follow a cat, the cat is
always going to surprise you.
But afterwards, you
can work out OK,
that's what that cat was doing.
And yet once you've
worked it out,
you can't go then
and predict what
the cat's going to do again.
Entities that are
unpredictable but not random.
That's maybe what you
mean by a flow of energy.
On the other hand,
I'm not sure I'm
going to be able to send
a probe to another planet
and wait for cats, much
less to talk to their elders
and see if they have
that same wisdom
that the elderly pope had.
Life can die.
We go back to Engles.
It's not that there
isn't life on earth
which is in one sense immortal.
Bacteria, in a sense,
never die from old age.
You can kill them.
Something that is alive is
something that can be killed.
And it's different from
a machine breaking down.
Because you can
take an old machine,
polish it up, install a few
new parts, and it works again.
But when death occurs, it
occurs catastrophically.
When that equilibrium is
finally lost, it crashes.
There is something about
the complexity of life
that means that death is
an essential part of life.
And yet 50 years
from now, 500 years
from now, 1,000 years
from now, will we
be able to take the pieces
of Frankenstein's monster
and actually glue them
together and make them work?
I don't want to have a
definition of life that
is overwhelmed by
changes in technology.
And yet this is
something that I feel
is an essential part
of what we are looking
for in our cultural
biases of 2015
when we say we're
looking for life.
Most importantly
though, we will not
know life until we see
more than one example.
The two fish are looking
at the snow globe.
And now they've got a
second universe to look at.
And the one says
to the other great,
now I'm going to have to come
up with a whole new cosmology.
Neither of them recognizing
that they're on a table,
on a planet Earth,
which we all know
is flat and surrounded
by mountains
and has a big dome over it
just like the snow globe does.
Or maybe it's surrounded
by crystal and spheres
like the fishbowl is.
Our knowledge is always
going to be incomplete.
That's why we keep looking.
There's one more thing, though.
To get back to my
original point that we
have to understand not only
the question of what is life,
as opposed to what makes life
interesting, as opposed to
how can we find it,
how can we describe it.
You can go to a Best Buy and get
a really good plasma screen TV.
You can get one with 3D glasses.
You can see
immensely fascinating
3D films in this plasma TV.
Now, the plasma TV has behind
it a whole set of pixels.
And the pixels are
very complicated.
If it weren't for the
pixels, the TV wouldn't work.
So what's real?
The image that you're seeing in
your head with the 3D glasses?
Or the pixels making the image?
Well, to quote the great
philosopher Dumbledore,
just because it's in your
head doesn't necessarily
mean it isn't real.
Because while it's true that
the pictures would never
be created without
the pixels, no one
would ever have built the
pixels except that they
wanted to watch the movie.
And furthermore,
confusing the two things--
I mean, if you're
looking at the movie
and you suddenly are
able to see the pixels,
something's gone
very, very wrong.
That's the fundamental
philosophical mistake
behind vitalism.
Because it reduces
whatever life is
to one more magic ingredient.
And people want to say
that this was supernatural,
this is the thumbprint of God.
Not only is it the
God of the gaps,
but it's reducing god to one
more chemical that we just
hadn't distilled before.
At the end of the day
we have to remember
that we live in a universe
both of pixels and of stars,
and of the images
of pixels and stars
that are inside our brain.
As you've heard, the seven of
us who have these lectures going
have talked a lot
among ourselves.
When I first presented
these ideas to that group,
I said the important
thing to remember
is that we have to talk about
more than just the pixels
at the end of the day.
We can talk about life,
what is life, why is life,
functional, how can we
find it in other planets.
But we should never
forget the reason
why we're coming to
seven lectures on life
and not seven lectures
on plagioclase.
And at that, I hope that
the other people here
will be able to get as
many good laughs out of you
as I've been able to get.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]